fantastic beasts and where to find them
as directed by David Yates who's made
every single Harry Potter film in the
franchise ever since order of the
Phoenix and this stars Eddie Redmayne as
Newt Scamander a guy who is looking
through old New York City 70 years
before Harry Potter ever read his book
in school for various creatures that
have escaped his suitcase he goes around
collecting feared creatures who a lot of
people want exterminated immediately
because he feels that if he can take
care of them and nurture them he can
create a relationship with these
creatures thus showing other people in
the magic community at this time some of
these creatures really don't mean them
any harm so not only is newt trying to
go around New York City and find all the
creatures that have escaped his case
he's also trying his best to make sure
that no one finds out what's really
going on now obviously I'm a big Harry
Potter fan if you guys have been
following my channel this year I
reviewed every single Harry Potter movie
and I enjoy all of them some are better
than others so I was really excited for
this movie it's also written by JK
Rowling so this is the first time that
someone who is a hardcore Harry Potter
fan can actually go to the film to
experience things for the very first
time without actually knowing what's
going to happen also Harry Potter fans
can go to this movie and not be
wondering what they got right and what
they got wrong when they're comparing it
to the book because this is her original
screenplay and once again she has shown
herself to be one of the most
imaginative writers working today
I really enjoyed fantastic beats I so
admire her imaginative qualities as a
writer this world has so many cool
things in it that make the child inside
of me get really excited I love all the
creature design everything looked so
cool just like in all the other Harry
Potter films I want to own or at least
befriend at least half of the creatures
in this film but pushing my fandom of
the Harry Potter universe aside what I
really liked about this movie was the
way it's constructed David Yates once
again proves that he's a director who
understands this world which is why I'm
glad he signed on to the sequels to this
film and what he brings to this universe
is a great sense of how to direct really
epic action sequences and special
effects but he's also really good at
slowly building and setting up
characters and making us appreciate this
world without overly relying on our
knowledge of the Harry Potter universe
or Arlo
of the Harry Potter universe and that's
probably my number one favorite thing
about this movie unlike almost every
prequel ever made fantastic beasts and
where to find them does not rely on our
fandom of other films to make us
appreciate this one pretty much every
remake reboot spin-off sequel prequel
whatever they all have ties to the other
things that we like and some of them do
it way too much
my wife is a far bigger Harry Potter fan
than I am she knows everything about the
books she knows everything about the
backstory she can tell you everything
about anything Harry Potter ever she
knows it and except for one little
object in this film that she said as
soon as she saw it she knew what was
going to happen everything else was able
to surprise her and that's because
Rowling and II eighths and the entire
creative team behind this movie have
made a movie that stands on its own you
don't even have to have seen the Harry
Potter films to understand and
appreciate this movie it can be a world
on its own without having to even
experience those other films and that's
something to be praised they didn't rely
on tons of fanservice and references and
little visual cues to make us go oh look
that's that's great great-grandfather of
this character like we don't need that
in this movie because they set up a good
movie on its own Eddie Redmayne is
fantastic as Newt Scamander he's
vulnerable he's very likable and he's an
extremely accessible character but also
one that is good at hiding past pain
without making it seem cliched and Dan
Fogler as Kowalski this normal no Maj or
muggle who really wants to set up a
bakery who gets caught up in all this
he's the audience character you know
he's the guy who's constantly like hey
what's going on and they explain things
to him they're really explaining it to
us but he's that character he was so
good he really added a lot to this movie
a lot of really good humor while also
being the audience character he was the
comic relief as well and he never got
annoying he never felt like a sidekick
and that's something I was really glad
because as soon as he was like on the
mission with Newt I was like oh
this could oh okay
and by the end of the movie that
character was actually one of the most
emotional
of the film that actually did bring a
tear to my eye and I was sitting there
like am i kind of tearing up
I also really liked Kathryn Watterson as
Tina she's investigating the things that
are going on in New York City a lot of
things are scaring people weird sites
strange things are happening and I'm not
going to get too much into that I think
you guys should experience that aspect
of the film without me even saying
anything what I will say is that it's
awesome that's a lot of fun it's the
type of film that allows you to get
excited about future installments
without feeling like a setup movie my
two least favorite Harry Potter films
even though I like them were the first
two because largely they did feel kind
of like setup movies those were my
biggest flaws of the first two Harry
Potter films fantastic beasts does set
up a new world that we can appreciate
that we've already been to but this is a
previous time but it doesn't feel like
it's just a set up movie it feels like
it stands on its own as an extremely
entertaining film I loved it as for
issues I really only have a couple in
the earlier parts of the movie there are
two editing / CGI mistakes I noticed the
very first shot that we see a wide shot
the Statue of Liberty if you look to the
right of the frame I noticed that the
American flag jumped unnaturally and I
think that was actually a CGI mistake
that's a nitpick but since this is the
first time I saw this movie and I
noticed it right off the bat I think
other people probably will too there's
also a really strange editing choice
where two characters in the beginning
are walking past each other and the
shots jump extremely fast - Kathryn
Watterson and then back to Eddie
Redmayne and I was like ooh that's messy
editing there are some narrative lee
rocky points in the first act where
there are some scenes that feel kind of
like they're just entertaining scenes
that will be great as a scene that you
watch again but don't necessarily feel
like they fit in this story and just
like with any film like this that
requires a lot of explaining there are
some heavy exposition scenes mostly
given to Dan Fogler character so that we
as an audience can understand things and
sometimes it does feel like school and
that's really it I had a blast with
fantastic beasts my wife who's a huge
Harry Potter fan saw with me and she
loved it too I think people are really
going to enjoy
this movie especially if your Harry
Potter fans but even if you're not I
think it's a fun and accessible movie
that's going to get people excited I'm
gonna give fantastic beasts and where to
find them an a - this is the ninth film
in the Harry Potter universe and they're
still good that's amazing
so guys I just got back from AFI Fest in
California I have a lot of reviews
coming to you very soon tons of new
releases I saw Moana I saw split I saw
lala land
Patterson I saw as well a lot of really
cool reviews coming to you guys and
normally I like to split them up over
the course of a few days and let them
breathe a little bit and space them out
better but because I got so many you're
going to get a huge influx of reviews
coming to you guys very soon look
forward to that also as I said I
reviewed every single Harry Potter film
over the course of this year you're
going to get a link to that playlist in
a minute here I hope you do check those
out I had a ton of fun doing that you
guys are the best I look forward to more
fantastic beast film I'm glad this one
was actually exciting and fun thank you
so much as always for watching guys and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
you